В Україні - найбільша кількість прокурорів на сто тисяч
жителів серед країн Європи,
заявив днями міністр фінансів Олександр Данилюк.
Ми вирішили перевірити, чи це справді так.
Середній показник по Європі - близько 11 прокурорів на 100 тисяч мешканців.
Це дані Європейської комісії з ефективності правосуддя.
роте у деяких країнах кількість прокурорів перевищує цю цифру
більше, ніж удвічі. Це, приміром, Латвія, Литва та Росія.
У цих країнах у середньому 23 прокурори
на 100 тисяч населення.
Водночас, Україна - беззаперечний лідер за цим показником.
Тут нарахували понад 30 державних обвинувачів на 100 тисяч мешканців.
Натомість найменше прокурорів зафіксовано в Ірландії,
Франції, Італії, Австрії та Мальті -
не більше 4 на 100 тисяч населення.
Про те, що в Україні забагато прокурорів, говорять не перший рік.
У 2015-му Верховна Рада вирішила,
що з 1 січня 2018го їхня чисельність -
а це станом на жовтень 2017 року -
11 313 прокурорів,
має скоротитися принаймні до 10 тисяч.
Проте наприкінці минулого року парламент цю норму скасував.
Мовляв, зменшення кількості прокурорів
неминуче призведе до збільшення навантаження на них.
Утім, як наголошують оглядачі,
у цьому випадку кількістю намагаються "перекрити" якість.
Ефективність української прокуратури викликає значні сумніви,
а грошей з бюджету увесь цей апарат з'їдає чимало.
У Генпрокуратурі, приміром, працює близько двох тисяч людей,
половина з яких - прокурори. Також на рівні обласних прокуратур
штат державних обвинувачів надто роздутий,
хоча їхня увага частіше прикута до дрібних правопорушень.
Запорукою ефективної роботи прокуратури, на думку експертів,
має бути не багатотисячний штат, а належний професійний розвиток,
гарантії невтручання та виплата встановленої законом заробітної плати.
В Україні дійсно - найбільша кількість прокурорів
на сто тисяч жителів серед країн Європи.
За даними Європейської комісії з ефективності правосуддя,
їх майже втричі більше, ніж у середньому по Європі.
Проте кількість не означає якість:
українські реалії свідчать - ефективніть роботи українських прокурорів
залишає бажати кращого.